I would remain hopeful but
people generally do not come back from
the bottom of the ocean Captain David
Marquez was the naval commander of the
submarine USS Santa Fe do you find it
odd that there is no method of
communication that the passengers could
have had no I find it ominous I find
that it's a signal that cruising
capacitated I don't think they had a
pinger or anything though that we're
just communicating by text message yeah
it's a commercial organization they're
trying to be really Innovative and
Cutting Edge on our submarines we would
have more devices but we have a nuclear
submarine that costs two billion dollars
so we have the luxury of having all
those kind of things